[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos un
vídeo hablando sobre brasil y la
catástrofe política y económica por la
que está pasando este país pero antes
voy a contestar a otra gran pregunta que
nos habéis hecho en muchos correos y que
está relacionada con este otro tema
como sabéis visual polític lo fundamos
entre tres personas
alberto rfc enrique couto y yo que me
llamo enrique fonseca y muchos nos
habéis preguntado cómo nos conocimos
éramos amigos antes incluso de crear
este canal pues lo cierto es que si
precisamente nos conocimos en un
seminario titulado perspectivas
macroeconómicas de brasil
en el año 2012 y por aquel entonces casi
todos los expertos decían que brasil era
el país del futuro recuerdo que
estábamos en santander en el norte de
españá y conocimos a varios economistas
politólogos y hasta algún que otro ex
presidente todos ellos estaban de
acuerdo en que brasil iba a convertirse
en un país rico más de 200 millones de
habitantes la mayor parte de los cuales
empezaban a formar parte de una pujante
clase media
por aquellos años empresas españolas
como el banco santander o telefónica
estaban invirtiendo miles de millones en
conquistar el mercado brasileño no sólo
eso lula da silva era una rockstar tanto
para los analistas de izquierdas como
para los de derechas un modelo de
político capaz de combinar crecimiento
económico con políticas sociales sí
amigos de visual político en aquel curso
cualquiera que dijera que brasil no
tenía futuro sería tachado de loco
cinco años más tarde lula da silva ha
tenido que pasar por la justicia y su
predecesor a dilma rousseff ha tenido
que dimitir de su cargo el actual
presidente está acusado por cargos de
corrupción y brasil está en plena
recesión económica la inseguridad en las
calles ha llegado a tal punto que el
ejército ha tenido que desplegar tropas
en ciudades como río de janeiro para
evitar guerras callejeras
y os preguntaréis cómo hemos llegado
hasta aquí y ha ocurrido en brasil para
que haya pasado de ser la gran promesa
de latinoamérica a una auténtica debacle
tanto a nivel político como a nivel
económico hoy en visual político vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el país de las nueve divisas tal cual
como lo oís desde los años cuarenta
hasta finales del siglo 20 brasil pasó
por nueve divisas
[Música]
primero tuvieron el real después pasaron
a tener otra moneda que se llamaba el
cruzeiro luego tuvieron el cruzeiro novo
luego cruzeiro otra vez en los años 80
volvieron a cambiar su divisa por otra
que esta vez se llamaba el cruzado y que
también fracasó y tuvo que ser
reemplazada por el cruzado novo y os
preguntaréis por qué brasil ha tenido
tantas monedas distintas es porque les
gusta coleccionar billetes pues no la
respuesta es la inflación o bueno aún
peor que la inflación la hiper inflación
[Música]
durante décadas los brasileños se
acostumbraron a que su dinero valiera
menos que los billetes del monopoly
entre los años 80 y 90 este país llegó a
registrar inflación es de más del 4 mil
por ciento interanual eso significa que
si un día te tomas una cerveza en un bar
de sao paulo y pagas vamos a decir 100
cruceros al año siguiente cuando vuelves
al bar esa misma cerveza te costaría 400
mil cruceros los world es cuarto el
brasil estaba apartada del mundo aislada
del centro era considerada parte de la
periferia de la periferia del mundo
hablamos de un país que ha sufrido una
de las dictaduras militares más salvajes
de la región dictadura a la que
sucedieron gobiernos democráticos pero
extremadamente corruptos lo cierto es
que durante décadas brasil se dedicaba a
pedir préstamos al mercado internacional
préstamos que pagaba imprimiendo dinero
que eso generaba más y más inflación y
que hacían para remediarlo pues cosas
como aprobar leyes que prohibieran la
subida de los precios
[Música]
brasil ha intentado frenar la inflación
congelando los precios en las tiendas el
gobierno esperaba que otros gastos como
las materias primas y las ventas al por
mayor también bajarán de precio pero eso
no se ha llegado a materializar los
economistas de hoy en día dicen que
alicia vive en una especie de 'alicia en
el país de las maravillas'
sin embargo en el año 1994 las cosas
cambiaron radicalmente en ese momento el
gobierno nombró a un nuevo ministro de
finanzas
cardoso fue el principal arquitecto del
progreso de brasil este hombre sabía que
los comercios no subían los precios por
capricho la inflación es un fenómeno
monetario y por tanto la forma de
combatirla es no imprimiendo billetes
así que saco una nueva divisa el real
brasileño una divisa que por ley estaba
fijada al dólar esto significa que el
banco central no podía imprimir dinero a
su antojo porque la equivalencia entre
el real y el dólar debía seguir siendo
la misma y justo de un año para otro
esa hiperinflación que sufrían los
brasileños desapareció fijaros en la
gráfica porque se ve clarísimamente tras
la introducción del real los precios se
estabilizaron automáticamente
pero esperad un momento porque todo esto
es más complicado de lo que parece el
hecho de que un país deje de imprimir
billetes significa que ya no pueden
gastar a discreción por eso cuando
henrique cardoso llegó a ser el
presidente del país en el año 1995 tuvo
que llevar a cabo un programa intenso de
privatizaciones
[Música]
brasil permitirá la mayor entrada de
capital extranjero de toda latinoamérica
en campos como la generación eléctrica
las telecomunicaciones y las autopistas
sin embargo en contra de lo que podríais
pensar estas privatizaciones no
generaron protestas más bien todo lo
contrario por primera vez en su historia
los brasileños podían hacer sus compras
sin tener que hipotecarse y esto
beneficiaba sobre todo a las clases más
desfavorecidas a fin de cuentas las
clases altas siempre habían tenido sus
ahorros en dólares americanos por lo que
esta hiperinflación no les afectaba pero
no sólo eso el hecho de tener una divisa
estable significa un entorno de negocios
estable
de repente brasil se convirtió en un
país donde se podía invertir y así es
como comenzó
[Música]
década dorada de brasil en el año 2002
cardoso no podía volverse a presentar a
las elecciones porque la constitución
brasileña al igual que la estadounidense
limita los mandatos de los presidentes y
el nuevo presidente que eligieron los
brasileños fue este señor que veis aquí
que se llamaba y se llama ignacio lula
da silva probablemente casi todos los
que veáis este vídeo hayáis oído hablar
de él
lula era todo un símbolo de ese resurgir
de la izquierda latinoamericana
[Música]
pero a diferencia de otros políticos de
su generación como hugo chávez lula no
encabezó ninguna revolución en realidad
su política económica fue una
continuación del trabajo que había hecho
cardoso estabilidad monetaria seguridad
jurídica y políticas sociales
lula da silva dijo ayer que su gobierno
priorizará la lucha contra el hambre
pero advirtió que no hay ningún milagro
para resolver los problemas sociales y
económicos del país la llegada de lula
al poder coincidió con un subidón en los
precios de las materias primas los
productores de soja azúcar o ciertos
minerales estaban aún fire en otras
palabras todo aquello que brasil
exportaba se vendía a precios más altos
de lo normal a eso le sumas la seguridad
jurídica y un mercado de 200 millones de
habitantes y entiendes por qué brasil
estaba de moda
[Música]
y os preguntaréis porque lula da silva
se convirtió en semejante rockstar en el
panorama político internacional la
verdad es que el presidente de brasil
aprovechó ese torrente de dinero que
entraba en el país para acabar con la
pobreza
[Aplausos]
hablamos de uno de los países más
desiguales de todo el continente cuando
lula llegó al gobierno casi el 40% de la
población seguía viviendo en condiciones
de pobreza extrema por eso su política
estrella el programa bolsa familia
sonaba como maná caído del cielo
[Aplausos]
no es perfecto pero este programa ha
sacado de la pobreza a 22 millones de
personas sin arruinar al gobierno de
brasil concretamente este programa bolsa
familia consistía en una subvención que
se daba directamente a las familias que
enviaban a sus hijos al colegio para
recibir ese dinero tenían que probar que
efectivamente los niños estaban
escolarizados y asistían a las clases de
esta forma el gobierno mataba a dos
pájaros de un tiro' por un lado se
aseguraba de que los niños se educaban y
por el otro sacaba a millones de
familias de la pobreza
[Música]
este junto a otros programas sirvió para
crear una pujante clase media brasileña
pero no sólo eso al sacar a tantísima
gente de la pobreza brasil se convertía
en algo más que un lugar perfecto para
la mano de obra barata
de repente brasil se convirtió en un
mercado atractivo para todo tipo de
empresas es en esta época cuando grandes
multinacionales como el banco santander
o mastercard abren oficinas en el país
[Música]
tras décadas de hiperinflación pobreza
extrema y violencia en las calles brasil
de repente se convertía en la gran
promesa de latinoamérica pero esperad un
momento porque aquí no termina la cosa
en el año 2008 cuando el resto del mundo
empezaba a sufrir los efectos de la
crisis económica
los brasileños descorchaban champán con
esta noticia
los descubrimientos de petróleo en alta
mar podrían convertir a brasil en uno de
los principales exportadores de crudo es
más se puede pedir los brasileños lo
tenían todo y para celebrarlo el comité
olímpico les concedió el honor de ser el
país anfitrión de los juegos olímpicos
del año 2016 brasil estaba en todos los
periódicos económicos los ciudadanos
consumían como si no existiera mañana y
los que hacemos este canal alberto couto
y yo asistíamos a un curso de política
donde nos decían que teníamos que hacer
las maletas y marcharnos a sao paulo
donde no nos faltaría trabajo
sin embargo y como ya sabéis este
optimismo duró bastante poco sí es
cierto que comparado con
argentina-brasil era un paraíso de
seguridad jurídica pero también era un
país con unos precios totalmente
desorbitados para el salario medio que
disfrutaban los brasileños todo eso por
no hablar de los tremendos aranceles que
imponían al comercio exterior o de la
corrupción que todavía no se conocía
pero que estaba pudriendo los cimientos
del país pero de todo eso seguiremos
hablando en las próximas semanas hoy
vamos a cerrar este vídeo con eso que
dicen en las series de televisión
estadounidenses to be continued
[Música]
[Aplausos]
si no os queréis perder ese vídeo que
sacaremos próximamente ya sabéis
suscribiros al canal y mientras tanto si
queréis empezar a entender por qué
brasil es una economía tan disfuncional
podéis hacer click en este otro vídeo y
ahora la pregunta es por qué creéis que
brasil ha terminado con semejante crisis
cuando en principio todo apuntaba a que
iban por el buen camino de verdad puede
el escándalo de brecht jugar un rol tan
importante en la crisis brasileña
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]